hey guys welcome back to new rockstars
my name is Sam Bastion today I'm in the
mood to talk about the newest thor
ragnarok trailer that we've got during
San Diego comic-con while the first two
Thor movies can't really be described as
home runs for the north's franchise this
third and final installment might just
be the perfect recipe for a killer Thor
movie most of us have heard that this
film is taking a more comedic approach
which could have some of us worried Thor
feels like a serious franchise being
about gods and wars everyone speaking in
Old English but with director Taika
Waititi and one of the most incredible
casts in a Marvel movie I think it's
safe to say that this movie could save
the Thor franchise but enough about that
let's hop right into the trailer and
let's go hunting for Easter eggs roll
the clip so much has happened since I
saw you
I lost Miami like yesterday so that's
pretty fresh all right so right out the
gates we are introduced to the car sure
we have been given glimpses of this
planet in the first thor ragnarok teaser
but now we're seeing what looks to be
the entire capital city of this world
what planet is this again all right
Sekar the name should sound familiar to
marvel fans because your favorite green
skin strong man made quite a name for
himself on this world in the comics this
is the intimus planet from the Planet
Hulk storyline the desolate world where
the Hulk becomes a space gladiator
fighting aliens in arena for the
pleasure of the ruling class so cool out
of everything Marvel fans cry out for a
Planet Hulk movie is about third on that
list of demands well it doesn't look
like we'll be getting a solo whole movie
anytime soon it looks like they'll be
taking elements of the Planet Hulk
storyline and merging it with the
popular Ragnarok story pretty cool this
has been confirmed by the director of
the movie and Marvel Studios and both of
these stories seem to merge well
together now most of you have noticed
that there are numerous portals hovering
over this city on Sekar if you had to
guess what is in these portals are for
if you guess cosmic garbage chute then
you'd be correct
Chris Hemsworth himself confirmed that
those wormholes suck up scrap metal and
rocks and junk and sometimes even people
and tosses it onto a car the color and
eclectic landscape of this planet could
be because the inhabitants of the car
have repurposed different civilizations
architecture and tech pretty cool now
most of you might notice the faces that
were built on the side of presumably the
Capitol building slash home of the Grand
Master and some of those faces do look
somewhat familiar some consider the
creature on the bottom left could be
Hulk mainly because at the time of
Thor's arrival to Sekar Hulk has been
the victor of the contest the champions
of tournament that's held by the
Grandmaster and if you're going to put
anyone's face on the side of your
fortress lies won't be the victor of
your own tournament and yes we probably
all download the contest of Champions
app to our phones and it's a lot of fun
now the individual with the spiked
helmet may look familiar to you hardcore
comic fans and you casual fans of the
Wonder Woman movie because this
character exists in both worlds that's
right this boy looks to be the God of
War himself Ares
now Marvel DC both liked to dip into
popular mythologies but it doesn't mean
that these characters are similar
Marvel's got a war is different from
DC's God of War but Bo
are awesome I promise you I'm sure the
helmet doesn't look exactly like the
marvel Ares his helmet but out of all of
Marvel's big bads Ares would fit in
nicely with the contest of Champions
next we have a very small any-any
possibility of one of Marvel's most
obscure characters showing up in this
film if you look at the top of the tower
you might notice that this face has two
large round eyes and very prominent
snoot ring any bells I have a feeling
this could be a nod to Man Thing the
protector of the swamp man thing is one
of Marvel's most obscure characters from
their horror genre but this character
has plenty of cosmic adventures in fact
during the most recent Secret Wars event
a version of dancing was a part of the
Grand Master's contest of Champions
check that out in Deadpool secret secret
Wars if that is dr. Ted Sallis aka the
Man Thing then this might be the closest
we'll get to the character joining the
MCU
but who knows let's say optimistic
finally this might be the biggest Easter
Egg for Thor fans it's only within the
first 5 seconds of this trailer fans are
aware that there have been numerous
characters who have been worthy enough
to pick up meal there but not many have
showed up in these movies it's crazy one
particular individual has been teased at
least once and I believe that this is
the first confirmation of his existence
in the MCU that's right I believe beta
ray bill is that long face up there all
the lower two faces are a little tough
to identify we'd recognize that long
face anywhere I came to this conclusion
mainly because beta ray bill play such a
big role in the Planet Hulk comic with
his face on the tower he could have been
a victor at one point but maybe loss to
the Hulk or may have escaped stack are
all together at the very least is
probably a fighter from beta ray Bill's
planet I should also point out the wind
Thor tosses his hammer it's clearly in
New York City Thor might be following a
lead to track down however it's too late
he tries the subduer he failed and then
his hammer is crushed then I believe
he's dragged back to Asgard as a way to
strike fear into the hearts of the
Asgardians their greatest champion has
fallen within seconds of meeting hella
hellas and torches Asgard and toss the
store into that cosmic garbage disposal
that is the car I'm deciding to go with
this timeline mainly because Thor has
his long luscious locks and his full
beard when he is being bathed in flames
which is most likely on Asgard and when
he confronts hella in New York
New York is where the portal to Hell is
located we're hella escapes who knows
but I'm pretty sure it's the witnesses
the death of his home realm little hole
next clip then I went on a journey of
self-discovery
again we get confirmation in this clip
that the car is treated as a dump Homer
is literally standing in a pile of
garbage from ER guess that these aliens
then capture Thor and try to sell him to
the Valkyrie who then takes Thor to the
Grandmaster and to be entered into the
contest of Champions convoluted speaking
of the Grandmaster in our current
champion let's dive into them for just a
second it was confirmed at SDCC that the
Grandmaster isn't just an elder of the
universe like he is in the comic and
like the collector from the guardians of
the galaxy but he's also the brother of
the collector in the MCU no word on if
Benicio del Toro will reprise his role
as the collector in Ragnarok but Jeff
Goldblum seems like the perfect actor to
play in a mortal trickster God who likes
to pick creatures against each other for
his pleasure
he might be owned immortal in real life
I mean one can only hope but back to
hold for just a second SDCC also
confirmed that Bruce Banner has been
locked away inside the Hulk for over two
years it's been two years since age of
Ultron how the Hulk was able to hold
Banner back will definitely be an
interesting plot point and hopefully it
leads to these two warring factions
inside of one body finally working
together by the end of the movie at the
very least SiC Planet Hulk armor Marvel
I love it
I love it I mean almost as much as I
like the Hulk nod by Marvel by making
the Marvel Studios logo green it's very
cute Thank You marvel let's move on Wow
no idea
however God is the just isn't rated as
God
oh I miss this
and you know how to fight with me
now I want easily sound right and just
like that banner is back to his human
form did Thor do something to the Hulk
to make him change back we'll have to
wait and see but based on the past few
movies I'm guessing banner was not aware
what the Hulk has been doing this whole
time his first words in the trailer are
where are we kind of sounds like a
scared and flash excited kid but this
means he just lost two whole years of
his life I mention sleepwalking and then
coming to two years later and here in
space I think this would be a perfect
setup for one of my favorite scenes in
comics Bruce and the Hulk talking to
each other we could have them enter
their own mind and have some really
thought-provoking and heartbreaking
revelations about how they feel about
each other for God's sake the whole
didn't even know how to speak until he
fours Bruce - shut up for a second
that's what I'm hoping for but maybe
we'll just have to wait for another
movie
as for the swirling cloud of nefarious
read this at least it's not like a
swirling garbage wring hole in the sky
right I don't know it doesn't look
similar to the other wormhole garbage
disposals but based on the plot my best
guess would be that this is either one a
result of hella torching Asgard and the
cosmos is in disarray or two this could
be a portal to search her yeah the fire
demon creature we saw in the final shot
of this trailer now this would be the
most terrifying because my gut tells me
the searcher is what brings on Ragnarok
as for what is Ragnarok
it's the Norse version of the apocalypse
but also kind of a rebirth in Norse
mythology
most of the major religious figures
during Ragnarok die off including for
Odin even Loki and so on it's a very
interesting concept and it will
definitely be exciting to see Aegis ever
once again try to cancel the apocalypse
he's been successful so far so who knows
also I like to point out that Thor's
haircut looks fantastic and it might
just be the way that the helmet sled
this hair but it looks like he's got a
little lightning bolt shaped into the
sides of his head was this a fun joke
from the hairstylist possibly or I'm
just seeing these also props to Marvel
for making this feel even more like an
80s movie with that Duran Duran cover
art on Bruce's t-shirt I'll come back to
why that shirt is ironic in just a
second now the next shot is presumably
the Thor gang escaping from the
grandmasters Tower in the Golden Circle
Eagle ship that's what I'm calling it
and seems a bit confusing to me does it
look like the entire hallway flips once
it exits the building
maybe the
these are two different shots that are
put together maybe the doorway looks
different from the outside compared to
the hallway maybe I'm overanalyzing this
and missing out on just how awesome this
ship is now there's no official name
released for it but you best believe I'm
buying the Lego version of it once it's
available best guess as to who is on the
ship the newly assembled a team Thor no
not natalie portman Erik Selvig and kat
dennings even though I did enjoy those
actors and characters no this time we
have Bruce Banner aka Hulk Valkyrie aka
Brunnhilde aka Tessa Thompson she's
beautiful and low-key because it
wouldn't be a Thor movie without those
two teaming up
yay can't wait for the banter between
Hulk and Loki to complement each other
they all seem to be heading straight for
that hellish portal careening around
pile of trash but before we go any
further Valkyrie well the character has
been demanded by fans for some time to
join the Thor films and even the
Avengers wouldn't mind having a few more
strong ladies on these teams and she has
been a part of the Avengers in the
comics so were covered Valkyrie her real
name Brunhilde was chosen by Odin to
lead the Valkyrie a team of warrior
goddesses and their main job was
transporting victorious soldiers who
followed Norse faith to Valhalla in the
trailer I'm guessing we see the Valkyrie
travel from Valhalla through that rip
down to hell to take on hello
while this scene is the definition of
epic my guess is that most of the
Valkyrie don't make it through this
battle but Tessa Thompson does succeed
in trapping hella for at least a few
thousand years from there it seems like
Odin may have exiled her from Asgard for
losing basically all the Valkyrie in one
fight or more likely Valkyrie abandons
her post out of shame now she's just
living out with the Grandmaster and has
lost her way
never fear though Thor will save her as
for her Pegasus I'd say that that was
pulled from the ultimate universe comics
there when she first appears in the
comics she's on a black Pegasus which is
pretty badass moving on in our next
scene we see Hello with her full
headdress along with Karl Urban skirts
the executioner now quick explanation
for the both of them hella of course is
the ruler of hell goddess of death and
it has a pretty unique power set
sure she's got the work she's got super
strength durability she's a skilled
fighter etc but do you know which of her
powers makes her such a terrifying
villain that would be her ability to
manifest weapons from anywhere on her
body we can
of this when she's throwing around just
way too many daggers like a crazy amount
also that headdress isn't just for
balance and hanging decorations she can
manipulate it and he use it as a weapon
as well we get a shot of her adjusting
her horns through some sort of
telekinesis but more on that in a second
oh and one last fun fact in the comics
fellas father is a very well-known enemy
of Thor he's even been in the movies
correct it's Loki and because of how
compacted this movie is I doubt that
this will be an additional twist to the
plot also that's just some comic book
gobbledygook we don't need all that
weirdness in this movie now as for
skirting the classic story antagonist
that always is scheming with Loki to
take over Asgard and in some tales he
does team up with Thor and the Asgardian
to save the realms but again in this
film it's already over stuff so he's
probably just gonna play a villain he
does have an impressive amount of skills
more specifically hand-to-hand combat
and tracking skills so my guess is that
scourge will be hunting for Thor for
hella I think we even see some of Thor's
allies fighting security I'll get back
to that in just a second as for the
fight between Hulk and Thor of course
Hulk wins but I do appreciate this scene
as a setup for their brotherly rapport
we've seen cap and Iron Man explore
their friendship staying with Black
Widow and Hawkeye Vision Scarlet Witch
even Bruce and iron man so I'm
appreciative of the riders giving Thor a
friend in The Avengers but let's watch
the next clip as god is dead little be
reborn in lioness
I thought you'd be glad stealing near
the stopper here and now prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
immediately we see hell absorbing some
sort of energy through her antlers and
my guess is that this is possibly after
she's killed a few people maybe
absorbing that life energy of her
enemies makes her more powerful and
allows her to manifest even more weapons
and do one more interesting power which
I will come back to very soon hint it
involves these soldiers lined up to
protect Asgard remember those antlers
also I'm not sure who that general is
right there in the front can't really
see them possibly Volstagg no I doesn't
really look like Volstagg of actually
where is he in this movie anyways we see
scourge and he'll us standing together
in a golden hallway this is most likely
time Del's post aka the Bifrost
or the Rainbow Bridge he is its
protector and since later in the trailer
we see him with what looks to be
Asgardian refugees he's probably
defeated quickly by these two sorry
hundo let's check out the next clip so
I'm putting together a team the old days
surprise they discuss fun
right
loves being true nerd of Bruce Banner on
screen is so cool can't even nail a
handshake as fun as failed fist bumps
can be the scene also gives us a glimpse
as to how this team is formed in this
green room with Hulk and Thor you can
see Valkyrie in the background and she
looks very irritated by their friendship
my assumption is that the Hulk isn't the
first recruit it's al Curry probably
while Thor is imprisoned after getting
his ass handed to him by the whole tour
is able to convince Valkyrie to come out
of retirement and stop hell once and for
all you know a good old-fashioned
revenge story we also get to see her
costume change into that stylish white
warrior outfit and we have her walking
away from the team ship which is now
wrecked by all those fireworks no comic
book answer for you but my gut says that
the director just wanted a really dope
moment for Valkyrie and it is but keep
an eye on those foot soldiers
approaching Valkyrie those antlers look
awful familiar more on that soon thor
also says that he's building a team like
the old days confirming that it's been
at least two years since these two boys
have seen Iron Man or Captain America
they're going to be a bit surprised
about how poorly their friends have been
acting when they get back to earth
speaking of surprises the whole got a
haircut
at the pictures reveal of the entire
trailer many people are confused by the
whole crew look specifically his face
kind of looks like a different shape
than the previous movies but like with
TT the director has stated they're still
finishing up the CGI so Hulk will
probably look different this November
when movie is released also the scene
confirms that are not so Jolly Green
Giant will be making his way to has
guard notice those mountain ranges
behind him those don't look like the
mountains of trash we saw in SAC are no
no that looks like the background to
Asgard one surprise after another Loki
is here and he's chained up what
happened well he was ruling Asgard as
Odin in disguise with the last time we
saw him also he was in the Grand
Master's of ughing room in the first
teaser for Ragnarok so he's been a bit
busy my guess is that Loki most likely
escaped as God before he could be killed
by hella flee to Sekar and tried to rub
shoulders with the Grand Master but then
things went south quickly and Loki got
kicked out once again we'll see these
two brothers team up to save the
universe and Loki will probably betray
his brother because it's Loki we didn't
get a glimpse of Thor jumping out of one
of the windows of the Grand Master's
Tower why it's a little hard to tell but
he looks like he's jumping from a red
room and previously we saw that the
Hulk's apartment was the same color
scheme maybe the colors are different on
the outside of the building than they
are from the inside and I'm totally
wrong either way it feels like this is
the beginning of the team escaping from
Sekar the next scene gives us quite a
sweet moment between two brothers Thor
and Loki fire on some Sekar soldiers but
two things to pay attention to here one
the purple statue is of the Grand Master
clearly this guy has an echo bigger than
well you know you go from gardens the
galaxy vol 2 and I mean I guess that
kind of happens when you're an elder of
the universe and to these two foot
soldiers right here have Cylon eyes most
likely a nice nod to fellow sci-fi
series Battlestar Galactica very fun
next clip he's a fighter
here we go
I'm not a kind spam we've got
confirmation that Fenrir the wolf isn't
a Ragnarok clearly he's not a friend of
team Thorat but it is fun to see Hulk
taking on this colossal canine also
bringing back that Duran Duran t-shirt
their top song is hungry like the wolf
Hulk's fighting the wolf is pretty cool
also another gross fun fact Loki has two
kids in this movie that won't be
acknowledged thank God hello
and then mere Fenrir is Loki's son I am
okay if Loki doesn't have a family
reunion every five minutes in this movie
note when they are fighting they are
below the Rainbow Bridge in the water
the climax of this movie could have
either Fenrir or the whole thrown out
into the cosmos like Loki in the finale
of the first storm relief is probably
going to be a wolf next we see scourge
in what looks to be a colorful room on
Sekar so it's somewhat confirms that
he's hunting down team Thor to
exterminate them I also believe the shot
of Korg the rock creature shooting his
gun could be at scourge trying to hold
him off so that team Thor can escape who
is cord the rock man he's a cronin
warrior from the Planet Hulk storyline
dup a friend's banner so fans of that
story are pretty happy about his
appearance fun fact number one this is
the second Kron we've seen in the Thor
film we saw the first one in the dark
world but he kind of got turned into
pebbles by a mule near fun fact number
two tyke with TC does the mocap and the
voice of this character very exciting
also I should note that another popular
planet whole character has been
confirmed for this film and he's in this
scene there's that red figure flipping
and picking up soldiers that's meek he's
a bug like species of alien that looks
to have been upgraded for this movie ygv
stated that we'll be seeing meek in a
red exosuit and slimmed down for
Ragnarok looks like Marvel is really
trying to make those Planet Hulk fans
happy we didn't get a hand pressing down
on a button that looks to be some sort
of weapon and based on the cuff of that
jacket we can confirm that that is Bruce
Banner
so this is most likely in their escape
ship and banner is defending his friend
with a defensive attack this is
confirmed when we see a shot of another
ship crashing and Bruce shearing from
the cockpit of that escape ship I'm
guessing he blew that ship up when we
see that same escape ship crashing and
taking out to bridge supports I'm
guessing that they were shot out of the
sky by some of how US forces but the
interesting part of the scene is again
we see these antlered soldiers were they
trying to stop hello from invading
Asgard we finally see what has happened
to them we see that they're now sporting
glowing skull masks on their faces and
they're heading towards came to earth to
fight them that she has killed them and
then turned them into her own personal
army so cool I think that energy that we
saw hell absorbing earlier could have
been what turns these soldiers into her
own killing machines or this energy
could possibly work on any dead person
she could have an enormous army well we
finally get our glimpse of Heimdall and
he looks to be distressed possibly in
the middle of a bat oh my guess that he
and the other as Guardians are fleeing
and they're hiding in another realm and
looking for a way to reclaim their home
for Ragnarok can destroy everything
finally Thor is trying to take on Helen
in combat which does not seem like a
great idea she can literally call upon
any weapon she can imagine my guess is
that hand at hand or even sword to hand
comment isn't a way to take this curl
down no roll the next clip or amongst at
what were you the god of again
you see what looks to be Loki and Thor
attempting to escape hella through the
Rainbow Bridge possibly to earth we are
supposed to end up with Doctor Strange
on earth at some point in this movie
searching for Odin I mean maybe this is
that moment maybe Odin holds the key to
stopping Ragnarok and containing hell
either way doesn't matter because Loki
got knocked the hell out of that
wormhole mid-flight where did he land we
don't know we also get a glimpse of Loki
probably in the street of Sekar in the
middle of the battle based on the
architecture around them and then we
move on to hella throwing just way too
many swords just like too many whips say
so much money if she could just you know
pop by her throw a bunch of them down we
melt them down we sell them and hey
she's our hero do bad she killed like a
plants worth of people in the beginning
of this movie oops
our final shot before we see the store
Ragnarok logo which is badass is Thor
exploding out of lightning my guess is
that Thor is on a journey of
self-discovery in this movie trying to
find meaning without his hammer that
made him Thor I mean just look at the
inscription on the hammer whosoever
holds this hammer if he be worthy shall
possess the power of Thor but maybe he's
never needed the hammer maybe Thor could
harness the power of the Lightning
himself and this is how he's able to
defeat hella I mean again normal weapons
don't seem to do anything to her so you
gotta turn to superpowers here's what
could explain why he's spewing lightning
out of his pores it's been confirmed in
more recent Thor comics that milner was
some sort of prison for a powerful
cosmic lightning storms so maybe the
Odinson has tapped into that power in
this movie either way I would love it if
Thor just kept this lightning look the
Lightning coming out of his eyes it's so
freakin cool also awesome final shot of
the newly formed team Thor let's hope
none of them die let's watch this final
clip let's say goodnight just a couple
of hotheaded fools
yes saying walk like fire toilet water
I kind of like aya the whole like raging
fire - I like smoldering fire
sure it's fun to see Thor and Hulk have
a figurative dick-measuring contest but
do you notice the teeth in the
background almost belong to some giant
ass creature oh if you're skeptical
don't worry they do it whole probably
killed it and turn that creatures skull
into his bed photo Hulk's enormous bed
was released online and it kind of makes
sense if you're the most badass fighter
you're gonna need the most badass bed
damn last but certainly not least we see
a hawk launching himself at a freaking
fire demon this is searcher the person I
mentioned earlier who be voiced by mr.
Krabs aka Clancy Brown in the movie this
demon is one of Thor's top 10 villains
and he is not someone you can mess with
without his hammer I'm not sure that
Thor could last very long in a fight
researcher so hoax probably got
discovered but why is searcher here
why shove in yet another character in an
already overstuffed movie well I believe
he's been here the entire time remember
the fire that helath summons to
eradicate the people of Asgard
I think she's summoning the power of
this demon and possibly working with
searcher mm-hmm also remember the red
portal on Sekar that's the most likely
searcher right I mean is he trying to
escape somewhere is he we can have it in
another realm not enough information to
call it now but I'm excited to see all
these characters come together in
Ragnarok final note this movie should
lead almost directly into Thor beating
the guardians of the galaxy in infinity
war all some details have come out as to
how Thor directly runs into the
Guardians how do you think this will all
play out meaning the end of Thor going
into infinity war let us know in the
comments down below also where the heck
is Lady SIF and her gang of merry men
let me know down below be sure to like
this video and comment your thoughts on
my theories down below do you agree with
them or am i dead wrong also I love it
when you guys tweet me your theories so
we can talk about it on Twitter so
follow me and tweet at me at Sam batcher
thank you guys for watching be sure to
check out all of our other explainer
nerdy breakdowns I'll see you guys next
time